[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
are very
[Laughter]
we're so careful we got cat back hi
hello thanks for having me where you
been what's wrong i'm good i recently
got a dog with my boyfriend so i guess
that's a huge step but what kind of dog
it's a
mini cream dashing i just call it a
wiener dog though
it's a little weird yeah
yeah he's like yappy little [ __ ] you
say dashand that's how you're supposed
to say it what's the right way i
wouldn't worry
i never i thought it was doc's hunt yeah
that's what i thought how's it spelled
wait d-a-s-c-h-u-n
who's if they have a wiener dog they're
not calling them a doc duck shoe yeah i
call it a a sweet or not yeah never say
a wiener dog i think it's i think i
think he's a nazi really yeah the wiener
dogs yeah dude
that's hitler's official dog there were
nazi dogs i don't i don't know if
hitler's official is the best way to say
they train their dogs do i have an aryan
dog because he's blonde
don't be so excited wait no i don't say
aryan just say like say like anglo-saxon
or something make it a little easier to
dye the type of his nose just a little
bit of brown like a little brown patch
right there
like this oh that'd be pretty good yeah
technically real real aryans are like
north indian people what does a north
indian person look like what is a real
area yeah yeah yeah it's an ancient
tribe it's a it's an ancient tribe in
central asia so they had it wrong the
whole time oh so when tila tequila says
that she's uh aryan as [ __ ] that's what
she means she is kind of aryan though
does she have she's indiana no she's
alien dude she got blonde hair and she
got colored contacts she's still alive
yeah she's alive nobody knows actually
what's she up to
check smoke she's a conspiracy theorist
now she's like north she's like a
neo-nazi conspiracy
that's what looks hella north india see
that's the thing about the height most
people do it up here but it's actually
more horizontal you know this fool stole
all like all this [ __ ] and then he
[ __ ] it up so like first off this
is uh roman julius caesar you see his
you see his oh yeah the sick kyle is a
[ __ ] he just stole he was he was a
fanboy of all the past like big rulers
right he's a white labeler he wasn't
even original he's the white label ruler
he's a [ __ ] he's kirkland signature
he just appropriated all that [ __ ] none
of that [ __ ] is og maybe the iron cross
right but then that shit's celtic that
[ __ ] or like that's not even like he
takes people's lives
he took that [ __ ] from julius caesar
because he was a [ __ ] fan right he
took the swastika from asians right and
in aryan is because back then they
didn't do uh their like archaeology [ __ ]
was like still like new it wasn't that
like old yet but
he thought that those were the original
europeans oh yeah but there's there's
but they're asian so aryan used to just
be asian or he didn't know the right
words maybe he didn't know yeah he was
trying to say asian but he was like
alien
like that yeah he's really bad at asian
accents too
yeah hitler's a he's he's the ultimate
rebrand huh he rebranded just rebranded
everything bro like rachel dolezal
dolezal stole m bison's outfit too he
did he did steal him
i kind of
oh my god
is that buddhist is that is that the
buddhist symbol or what i was looking at
i looked up og swastika that was when
the first thing that came up
i think the bullets is the mirrored one
the sauce is gonna need to be mirrored
right yeah you don't know i came across
a video and it was like the real meaning
of the swastika is like peace and
prosperity
damn oh yeah like the buddhist one right
yeah it's peace and prosperity
so he just i think that's the difference
just seeing it mirrored one is one is
buddhist and one is i don't know which
one is which but
i think the one he just showed is
actually the
uh the non-buddhist one
the buddhist one has imagine wearing
this
oh my god so which one are you saying no
today you're wrapping it though
you're like kind of repping it aren't
you you're like no
no you can't wear them how did you find
that one well like i said i googled og
swastika logo this is one of the other
things do they sell both shirts on the
same site it's different options
different options you find this on
alibaba yeah yeah that's true in germany
it's illegal to have the swastika in
pictures art film anything even buddhist
[ __ ] even for like yeah for like uh like
like what do you call it like period
pieces when yeah when you're trying to
do it for like example or whatever you
can't you can't show it at all they
can't afford it they can't afford so how
do they teach about the holocaust if
they can't show anything they ignore it
they just don't talk they show old
footage but they can't like animate it
and make something new and all that
stuff maybe that's where study abroad
programs came from but like we can't
teach this learn over there
we're all german exchange students
learn it
i do wonder how that stuff comes out
like for example when we see like
american entertainment movies and stuff
that like totally just constantly bashes
on other countries like just redoing war
movies over and over again just
constantly talking [ __ ] about like japan
or whatever
i'm like do do they show these movies in
their countries for sure they do
probably not not in china you know what
i'm saying like if it has anything like
we're always talking [ __ ] on like russia
japan
north korea
like all these places yeah it's
propaganda do you remember that movie
the interview that they did with seth
rogen yeah the north korea one they show
that north korea all the time i hear
i hear that all the time i feel like
you're lying look see i don't know if
you can see this here but the buddhist
swastika oh
i learned when i was a kid to tell the
difference they said the buddha swastika
is the person that's like walking with
his feet whereas the nasty cross is one
that's like hacking with a knife dude
all they did is just turn it diagonally
if it if it turns uh they just mirrored
it and diagonaled it what a [ __ ]
bunch of stuff look at this [ __ ]
oh my god what the [ __ ]
that's so confusing that's that's the
hitler cross that's a nazi cross i think
steve is designing these shirts
he's changing it up this is salon.com
bro you bought it with the ust oh it
says that they tried to reclaim the
swastika that it didn't go very well no
way a little [ __ ] what company though
like a buddhist company some called some
company called ka design dude i want to
see a
bunch of buddhists like standing up and
saying dude we need to take over the we
need to take the swastika back no but
that doesn't stand for like peace and
stuff the chill they're just like that's
true that's true that's true let's check
this out the swastika they say the
swastika is 5000 years old it's a symbol
of peace the nazis took the swastika
and but now the swastika is coming back
together with peace together with love
together with respect together with
freedom and everyone's like hey [ __ ] you
guys
if the shirt wasn't such a [ __ ] design i
would wear it i like the color scheme
though i'm a fan of the color scheme how
long do you think until swastikas make a
rebrand i'm scared i don't know about it
how long know how many years we're not
gonna do it when can we wear them again
guys there was a there was an incident
that happened like in the oc where this
uh you know how like yeah the swastika
is buddhist right so this girl was
wearing like a jade necklace with like
swastika like around the thing yeah
buddha swastika yo and then like
um basically she got into an altercation
with this old lady that started
lecturing her about the nazism and
jewish [ __ ] and like all that and she
was just like
i'm not a [ __ ] nazi like and they
wouldn't listen and i don't know it was
like a whole news thing on it it was
pretty wild that's pretty risque but i i
mean like if it's still happening now
yeah dude imagine because like when you
talk to a nazi back in the old days
they're like i'm a hell of a nazi bro
i'm a [ __ ] absolute nazi you know
what i mean like they didn't go like i'm
not a nazi
it's crazy how like just symbols
represent something and it's hard to
like break the meaning from it because
when when i was up to when i was like
maybe second or third grade i understood
like the jewish symbol was the star of
david but that's also the same shape for
sheriff so i thought all sheriffs were
jews
up until like maybe i was like in third
grade and i was like oh wait no they're
actually different they might be they're
fairly different yeah but i get it no i
see i see where you're at you know right
okay start because
the star of david is only used in two
two instances that i've seen the christ
like the cross and then seeing the
upside down cross but you're like it's
still a cross it's still a t yeah but it
wasn't upside down the sheriff can this
ever get a rebrand no that's universal
dude right well this was going through a
hard time remember when this is going oh
it's all right
because you can't say okay because it's
a white house
oh it's a white power w and then it goes
like a p i guess but it's not but it's
not it's supposed to be like what made
you looking soccer exactly it's a 4chan
prank there's a joke right and they and
then these [ __ ] idiots bought into it
and they started yeah i was taking
pictures like that be like ha got you
and then you punched somebody right and
then and i was like people were like
don't do that that's that's white
supremacy yeah so i'm i'm gonna say this
means okay
not white power and also in certain
countries it means butthole so
oh that big yeah
we looked it up i thought this was it
yeah i feel like when you go like this
that's you this is me though am i right
no this means
because that's why it's his website
spider-man yeah he does it like that he
don't you don't shoot upward like rock
on bro spider-man says hey rock on he's
a real metal head that guy i think
symbolism is different too depending on
like where you are right because like i
think if you flip people off in like
asia or whatever they'll just be like
i like this
that's true that doesn't really mean
anything yeah my when my grandpa would
stay with us in the summer like he he
points to this middle finger because
it's the longest finger right so he'll
like be pointing stuff at me and i'm
just like giggling because i'm a [ __ ]
stupid little kid because i i think of
this right but then for him he's just
like oh yeah it's that one over there
yeah they like to point with their
middle finger the finger's the longest
i'm gonna start doing that yeah i'm sure
you read with their middle finger yeah
he literally reads like this or he goes
to elevate he presses his middle finger
does he do it like this with a thumb out
real loose did he also have a super
super long pinky nail to scratch and
pick his nose dude imagine pissing
somebody off or something
that guy right
new age vietnamese old vietnamese has it
to pick your nose new age vietnamese
coke in the bathroom okay i always
thought it was for a month today's video
is brought to you by curology you know
recently i talked to people
i've been trying to meet up with people
more for business
and then they see me and then once they
find out that i'm 36 they're like what i
thought you were 25.
and i think it's because i've been
taking care of my skin a little bit more
so i look more youthful when did you
start your skincare journey i tried on
and off
uh starting when i was like in high
school
but i think in high school i did too
many drugs and i think there's lots of
toxins that come out and then also i
think it's hard to stick to things when
you're younger like washing your face or
washing your teeth or even brushing or
showering i used to sleep with my
contacts in my eyes for like two weeks
straight you know but then now when you
get older like you feel like you gotta
take care of your body more so you're
way more disciplined where you're like
you know what
if i don't shower before i sleep at
least wash my face or if i don't do this
i'll at least do that so i i've been
able to stick to it way more and you do
see a difference i'm bougie now dude i
have to jump in the pool before i go to
sleep the pool yeah i just well i just
need i needed i need to rinse oh you
know yeah yeah yeah but what's cool with
curology is they make this effortless
they make it super easy you go ahead on
their website you take a quick survey of
what your goals are anti-asian
anti-wrinkle asian no aging aging
anti-acne whatever you know whatever
your goals are you're oily you're too
dry whatever they can create this
formula for you and i've been using it
for about two years now and i think it's
pretty awesome because i
don't like cleaning products okay
i'm known to be a disgusting human being
and i just rinse with water but you know
curology made it so simple for someone
like me
and uh i was like you know what if
they're just gonna hook me up i'm gonna
use their face wash that comes in the
package i use that in the shower after
that i have my special formula that i
use for my face and they got a
moisturizer too so it's been pretty
simple and to me it keeps the thinking
out of the whole thing but what's also
cool is they have a licensed dermatology
provider that helps formulate all of
this for you so you don't have to feel
like it's somebody that's just making
things up so if you're ready for
healthier skin and you want to look
bright and young and youthful make sure
you go to curology.com
off the record to get your first 30-day
trial for free all you have to do is pay
for shipping and handling that's a whole
month's worth go to curology.com off the
record hey is it is it normal for a
vietnamese family to after eat hotpot
like drop e together and have e puddles
only if they're only if they're like 45
years old because like no joke like my
friend was like
normal is this normal in like vietnamese
families where like like afterwards like
the whole family gets together and like
they they drop eat and i was like i
don't think that's normal dude and
they're like yeah my friend in vietnam
says it's normal the whole family drops
e oh they're like in the motherland
doing it yeah well they're like their
friend is like
new immigrant vietnamese right and i was
like i was in vietnam and i swear to god
i didn't see like whole families like
hugging each other doing e-puddles
after after dinner i didn't see that
what's the e-puddle like when you're
like all puddled and huddling up and
you're all yeah it's like a cuddle
puddle but you're all like on e yeah
like kind of massaging each other you
know like stroking each other's arm dude
i would love to do e with my mom and my
back dude
huh why would you want to do it oh no i
was joking i would never want to do that
oh i was not jumping ketamine with my
family though you guys down you guys
trying to see some k holes
he was mentioning doing coke before jk
when it becomes legal yeah yeah i've
never done it before on jk yeah that's
crazy that's too hardcore man it's a
small line just a smile let's do the
greatest patreon run of all time for us
it's not about partying it's about
seeing if we can give more yeah to you
know people who follow at the very end
we're all going to be business
partners yeah dude that's more the e
yeah i think by the very end i'll be
like sleeping there
and
but you've never done coke yeah exactly
me neither on jk i've only smoked crack
you guys are crazy straight to the
source huh yeah but i was a teen i feel
like the things that you do as a teen
you're a different person and you're
allowed to test the world at that age
and after you pass that phase by the
time you're like
well into your 20s maybe experimenting
should be like chilling out and then
like 30s and 40s and all that then you
have a problem no no no no no incorrect
i think first of all in your 30s and 40s
is when you become an adult about the
substances that's true it's not about
doing it for parties to do it to like
better your like life experience or
enhance your relationships but if it's
like not psychedelic and it's just like
the hard [ __ ] like you're smoking meth
every day i disagree that's why we gotta
do coke before we do jk dude so we can
enhance our relationships and bonds
first of all give me one session me and
you i will [ __ ] enhance that [ __ ]
dude
there are socially acceptable things
though like mushrooms mushrooms are
pretty fire though for like a
psychedelic bonding experience have you
ever done mushrooms no i want to do so
many drugs but i'm afraid because i'm
too old now i feel like because i didn't
oh what are you talking about see you
should have done it in your teens girl
i'm telling you i wish i did all i i
wish i [ __ ] more i wish i did more
drugs and i wish i drank more as a
teenager joe rogan does everything he's
[ __ ] 50 something i think [ __ ]
later in life is better than earlier i
think so too yeah really for sure
[ __ ] i started early everything else
i never really did i never really got
into but you didn't [ __ ] much uh no i
[ __ ] a lot because i had a but you
wanted to [ __ ] more
no i wish i [ __ ] other people because
i have
a lot of [ __ ] experience but not a
lot of partner experience
right like i like i can count the amount
of people that i [ __ ] on one hand and
it's not all my fingers
well like i [ __ ] consistently since i
was 15.
uh so if you [ __ ] come on cat get
those numbers up bro i know you could
still be a total [ __ ] [ __ ] though if
you [ __ ] one guy like a thousand times
yeah
i'm totally such a [ __ ] i thought
because my boyfriend you should do porn
i could convince him into letting me
have a threesome but he's such a prude
now after porn wait so with two dudes
yeah oh [ __ ] and he won't do it no he
won't do it has he done it before
he's had tons of threesomes well is he
like bored of it you gotta give him
adult drugs so they can start bonding
again and or is he like is he like i
don't wanna work that's a good strategy
right he's just like he's lived so much
when he was younger that now he's like
mellowed out he's like calm is trying to
be a dog dad meanwhile like i never had
those years to like experiment and have
that crazy fun so now i want to do it
but he's not down it's kind of like a
[ __ ] huh yeah it sounds like the train
left because he just enjoyed the ride
without you i know that's what i'm
saying i told him he robbed me of like
what's left of my best last name so he
should let you go experiment i wish he
says no to be fair though like you hear
about like senior citizens and like
senior homes and stuff that like just
start [ __ ] going crazy
stds
[Laughter]
let's say he does let you yeah
do you think you would take advantage of
that yes now i would he's like i can't
wait who's your top [ __ ] list if he
starts
so say you guys do a threesome two guys
and you yeah you would you think it
would kill the mood if he cried the
whole time yeah the whole time um is it
loud crying or like
like quiet like like trying to hide it
still the emotional car or like pain in
the butt crosstalk that's like right
but like you know he's he's still doing
it because he's a true so much like this
dude is down for the blog
realistically i think i'd feel bad after
but during i'd probably just keep
moaning to like drown out the sound yeah
just louder and louder yeah start
turning up the music louder because this
moment's about me it's not about you you
had your moment this is my moment this
is my make-a-wish let me get my nut dude
you're the one that already had a
threesome yeah yeah yeah so like let me
live you know we'll talk about how many
dudes in here can do two guys one girl i
can do it but i gotta cry the whole time
i'm off and steve's about dude i'm okay
yeah we're crying though i'm crying but
you can't
would you have a preference of like
whether you're in the front or in the
back if it was your wife um both because
i'll kill that [ __ ]
you can like you can have another dude
in the room with your chick he believes
in brotherly love a pro
honestly
be like very very honest with myself
it's possible what if in the heat of the
moment right you guys are [ __ ] doing
it high fiving each other and he just
goes and grabs her dicks and goes
like oh [ __ ] now a man no this is like
it's like a moment man there's got to be
rules
you got to set rules beforehand
yeah but rules are meant to be broken
uh do you have to know the dude or no as
weird as it sounds as i'm really trying
to be serious about this question as
weird as it sounds
probably be easier to freak how many
years it's easier if it's a homie versus
a stranger yeah it's easier if it's
telling me oh [ __ ] i i get i think if
it's a stranger i'm like that's gay yeah
really yeah i'm like i don't need to be
in a [ __ ] a threesome with a strange
dude but he's [ __ ] her chick though
he's not gay that's worse that's what
i'm saying like that's like whack for me
to do that i gaze the wrong word but you
know i mean for me what i would feel i'd
be like why is this other dude in this
space i'm not actually not thinking
about the it being my girl because that
sucks right now but um
in the idea of hurts all of our feelings
you know
my own feelings right now but in the
idea of it i wouldn't want to be like
why i'm in the situation with a ran now
now i'm doing a porn threesome with
somebody i don't know so i need to get
paid for it but if it's a genuine joe
shirt
and joe's like this
rules are meant to be broken as he
reaches for your dick
dude with his mouth open and [ __ ] just
listening to the rules before playing
he's like yeah okay got it cool don't do
that excellent
cool go go go go go
breaker
i'm too scared man what are you scared
of a hard dick
like where though like in the vista in
the vicinity what would be better for
you a homie or a stranger if you had to
do
two guys
bart's dick or someone you don't know
stranger
stickers i don't have to see them ever
again right true and it's one of those
things where it's like we did do it but
can we just not let's forget about this
but if it's a good friend
then it's like you might be jet skiing
together or whatever and you look over
yourself
often you jet ski with the
maybe we might be jet skiing and we're
just like just you know or like we might
be on a roller coaster how often do we
ever just dude we might i don't know
like we might be shooting guns or doing
something else and that thought it goes
into your mind look it goes into your
mind and you're like just for fun i saw
your dick
in the mouth of my girl that's why we
got that's why we gotta take the your
girl out of it if you take the girl out
of the variable then it's different
they're not two guys in a stranger girl
for example
i'm gonna put a series like like let's
say like my boy mike song right
obviously he would never do it i don't
want to but for [ __ ] fun i'm gonna
say this mike's in bro i think yeah if
me and mike were there obviously it was
this different random person i think no
matter how [ __ ] weird that is i'm
looking at him the rest of my laughing
bag we are very close yeah you got a
special bond yeah especially like that i
get you that's not a special one you
guys got to get some matching t-shirts
that says rule breaker i'd be like
[Laughter]
why it's not your wife that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying take a
stranger girl oh that's different yeah
that's my brother forever yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i i hear you're saying it's a half night
stand i'm not saying i want that or
desire i'm saying can i all the way up
here to down here no it's all good one
nice stand half night stand hey we're
bringing we were being pretty careful on
this one dude yeah we're very we're
right here we're very careful i think
we're trying to be honest with our
answers you know yeah we do the nazi
shirts
we're
we had a careful time thanks for coming
to the careful show we'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you